pollution est gratuite facebook twitter
google nous tous les agences et
ministères fédéraux se servent
abondamment des plateformes numériques
pour s'adresser aux canadiens les
canadiens n'ont pas idée des sommes
considérables que le gouvernement
dépenses en publicité en ligne sur
google et facebook souligne le directeur
général du groupe canadien pour une
fiscalité équitable selon des données
compilées par radio canada pour les
années 2010 8 et 2019
le gouvernement fédéral a dépensé plus
de 52 millions de dollars en publicité
chez les géants numérique
ceux que l'on surnomme les gaffes à gogo
notamment a reçu plus de 24 millions de
dollars facebook plus de 16 millions et
twitter plus de 3 millions durant cette
période
mais je n'ai pas de vie pour ses
publicités en ligne le gouvernement
fédéral a dépensé cinq fois plus chez
les gaffes à qu'ailleurs sur le web un
fait troublant
aux yeux de ce groupe de pression ce
sont les plus grandes entreprises du
monde à pratiquer l'évitement fiscal et
nous utilisons l'argent public pour leur
acheter de la publicité souligne-t-il
d'autant plus grave aux yeux de
l'opposition à ottawa
dans le contexte de la crise des médias
c'est indécent affaires de voir que
pendant une crise
pendant que nos médias et notre culture
en général appelle à l'aide le
gouvernement investisse cinq fois plus
dans les gars forts qui ne paient pas ps
je comprends le gouvernement trudeau
s'est engagé à imposer les revenus des
géants du web généré au canada par les
ventes de publicité notamment mais
l'échéancier pour y parvenir demeurent
floues un porte parole du bureau du
ministre des finances écrit nous
continuons de travailler avec nos
partenaires internationaux dans le cadre
de l' ocde pour élaborer une approche
commune on a l'impression que on est
entré une recul est oui
on a des craintes au npd que ça sera pas
fait dans un an ou dans deux ans c'est
vraiment une très grande injustice
les libéraux ont fait de l'équité
fiscale pour les grandes entreprises
numériques
un thème important de la dernière
campagne électorale plus ils tardent à
réaliser cette promesse plus certaines
contradictions comme l'achat de
publicité en ligne aux géants du web
pourrait leur nuire ici louis blouin
radio canada ottawa